.
IGNORE THE FACTS.
FREEDOM.
AND THE REPUBLICAN DENIERS ARE
ALSO IGNORING THE FACTS OF WHAT
WE ALL SAW, AND WHAT WE ALL
HEARD ON JANUARY 6th.
THAT'S WHEN BLOOD-THIRSTY
TRUMP-SUPPORTING RIOTERS,
STORMED THE HALLS OF CONGRESS,
BEATING POLICE WITHIN AN INCH OF
THEIR LIVES, FORCING LAWMAKERS
TO RUN FOR IT.
OR MAYBE IT'S NOT THEY'RE
IGNORING THEM.
MAYBE THEY'RE SCARED OF THEM.
WITH THE SELECT COMMITTEE
THREATENING SUBPOENAS, DOES THIS
GUY SEEM NERVOUS TO YOU, JIM
JORDAN?
>> DID YOU SPEAK WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMP ON JANUARY 6th?
>> I SPOKE WITH THE PRESIDENT
LAST WEEK.
I SPEAK WITH HIM ALL THE TIME.
I SPOKE WITH HIM JANUARY 6th.
I TALK TO PRESIDENT TRUMP ALL
THE TIME.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S UNUSUAL.
I WOULD EXPECT MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS TO TALK WITH THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
WHEN THEY'RE TRYING TO GET DONE
THE THINGS THEY TOLD THE VOTERS
IN THEIR DISTRICT TO DO.
I'M ACTUALLY AMAZED SOMETIMES
THAT PEOPLE KEEP ASKING THIS
QUESTION.
I TALKED TO THE PRESIDENT ALL
THE TIME.
>> ON JANUARY 6th, DID YOU SPEAK
WITH HIM BEFORE, DURING OR AFTER
THE CAPITOL WAS ATTACKED?
>> I WOULD HAVE TO GO -- I SPOKE
WITH HIM THAT DAY AFTER.
I THINK AFTER.
I DON'T KNOW IF I SPOKE WITH HIM
IN THE MORNING OR NOT.
I JUST DON'T KNOW.
I WOULD HAVE TO GO BACK -- I
DON'T KNOW THAT -- WHEN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS HAPPEN.
BUT WHAT I KNOW IS I SPOKE WITH
HIM ALL THE TIME.
>> COME ON.
HUMINA, HUMINA.
YOU SPOKE TO HIM JANUARY 6th.
YOU DON'T KNOW WHEN THE
CONVERSATIONS HAPPENED.
BUT YOU SPEAK WITH HIM ALL THE
TIME.
PLEASE.
YOU EXPECT US TO BELIEVE THAT
YOU DON'T REMEMBER WHEN YOU
SPOKE TO THE PRESIDENT THE DAY
THE CAPITOL WAS ATTACK BY
RIOTOUS-HUNTING LAWMAKERS.
YOU WERE THERE.
IN THE HALLS OF CONGRESS.
AND CHANTING HANG MIKE PENCE,
BUT YOU DON'T REMEMBER WHEN YOU
SPOKE TO THE PRESIDENT?
YOU DON'T REMEMBER?
REALLY?
AND THEN, THERE'S KEVIN
McCARTHY, WHO IS SO DETERMINED
TO DOWNPLAY WHAT HAPPENED ON
JANUARY 6th, HE CALLS IT AN
ALTERCATION.
>> WE'VE WATCHED THE SERGEANT OF
ARMS HAVE TO PASS A NOTE TO THE
SPEAKER DURING THE ALTERCATIONS
ON JANUARY 6th, WHETHER TO CALL
THE NATIONAL GUARD.
>> PATHETIC.
I'M JUST GOING TO SAY IT.
PATHETIC.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT?
IT'S NOT EVEN THE BODY
LANGUAGE -- IT'S SO FAKE.
IT'S SO FAKE.
ACTING.
AN ALTERCATION IS DEFINED AS A
NOISY, HEATED DISPUTE, THAT
DOESN'T BEGIN TO DESCRIBE THE
VIOLENCE, THE BLOODSHED, WHEN
RIOTERS RAN WILD IN THE SEAT OF
OUR DEMOCRACY, TRYING TO
OVERTURN JOE BIDEN'S VICTORY.
DOES THAT LOOK LIKE AN
ALTERCATION TO YOU?
THAT'S AN ALTERCATION?
OKAY.
AND JUST LISTEN TO THIS
MISH-MOSH AS KEVIN McCARTHY
TRIES REALLY HARD NOT TO SAY A
WHAT ACTUALLY HAPPENED ON THAT
PHONE CALL WITH THE
THEN-PRESIDENT THAT DAY.
>> WHEN I CALLED THE PRESIDENT,
I WAS TELLING HIM ABOUT WHAT WAS
HAPPENING IN THE CAPITOL BECAUSE
NONE OF YOU WOULD KNOW UNLESS
YOU WERE IN THE CAPITOL.
LO AND BEHOLD, THE INFORMATION
WE HAVE TODAY, I DIDN'T KNOW AT
THAT MOMENT IN TIME, THAT PELOSI
HAD BEEN PASSED A NOTE, CAN YOU
CALL THE NATIONAL GUARD?
I DIDN'T KNOW AT THAT TIME,
DECEMBER 14th, THEY KNEW.
I DIDN'T KNOW THE SERGEANT AT
ARMS SAID HE COULDN'T HAVE IT
BECAUSE OF OPTICS BECAUSE THEY
NEVER SPOKE TO US.
IT'S PURELY A POLITICAL
POSITION.
>> FUNNY.
THAT'S NOT WHAT CONGRESSWOMAN
JAMIE HERRERA BUTLER SAYS
HAPPENED.
SHE SAYS WHILE THE CAPITOL WAS
UNDER ATTACK, KEVIN McCARTHY
CALLED THE THEN-PRESIDENT,
BEGGING FOR HIM TO CALL OFF THE
MOB.
TRUMP'S STONE-COLD RESPONSE,
WELL, KEVIN, I GUESS THESE
PEOPLE ARE MORE UPSET ABOUT THE
ELECTION THAN YOU ARE.
AND THEN, THERE'S MO BROOKS.
YOU REMEMBER HIM, WHIPPING UP
THE CROWD BEFORE THE RIOTERS
STORMED THE CAPITOL.
>> TODAY IS THE DAY AMERICAN
PATRIOTS START TAKING DOWN NAMES
AND KICKING ASS.
>> HMM.
DID YOU SEE THE HAT?
FIRE PELOSI.
NOW, WE'RE LEARNING THAT HE WAS
WEARING BODY ARMOR WHEN HE SAID
THAT.
THAT SEEMS ODD IF YOU'RE NOT
EXPECTING TROUBLE.
AND HE IS STILL TRYING TO BLAME
BLACK LIVES MATTER AND ANTIFA
FOR WHAT WE KNOW WAS AN ATTACK
BY TRUMP SUPPORTERS.
REMEMBER?
ALL OF THE EVIDENCE,
INVESTIGATION, NO ANTIFA, NO
BLACK LIVES MATTER.
TRUMP SUPPORTERS.
NO BLACK LIVES MATTER.
NO ANTIFA.
TRUMP SUPPORTERS.
TRUMPLICANS.
TELLING CNN, THE REASON WAS, I
OFTEN WEAR BODY ARMOR BECAUSE OF
ALL OF THE DEATH THREATS AND
THREATS OF VIOLENCE THAT I AND
OTHER CONGRESSMEN GET.
WE WERE WARNED BY THE HOUSE
SERGEANT AT ARMS THAT THREATS OF
VIOLENCE AGAINST ME HAD SPIKED
IN DECEMBER 2020 AND JANUARY
2021.
BUT THE ONLY THREAT I WAS AWARE
OF ON THAT DAY WERE BLM AND
ANTIFA.
HMM.
OKAY.
IF YOU BELIEVE THAT.
TALK ABOUT FAULTY INTELLIGENCE
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT WHAT
HAPPENED.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THESE THREE,
YOU CAN SEE THE DIRECTION THE
INVESTIGATION WILL HAVE TO GO
AND WHAT IT'S GOING TO TAKE TO
GET TO THE TRUTH, NO MATTER HOW
HARD THEY TRY -- THEY MAY TRY TO
HIDE IT.
SO, THAT BRINGS US BACK
FULL-CIRCLE, TO THE TRUTH.
THE FACTS WE NEED TO SAVE OUR
DEMOCRACY.
AND OUR LIVES.
THIS IS A BREAK GLASS MOME